Hollywood created a certain way
information is consumed one of the
reasons from the president Trump was
elected was because the way that we
consume information has been changed by
the media industry across Hollywood and
New York a couple sets up a camera in
their home to capture a supernatural
presence haunting them a family fights
to survive the night when the US
government makes all crime legal for 12
hours a black man goes to his white
girlfriend's house and discovers their
sinister plans for black people these
are just a few of the high concept films
produced by Blum house productions
founded by Jason Blum at 35 Jason Blum
moved to Los Angeles and found himself
producing a micro budget horror film
called Paranormal Activity the film
ended up being made for only $15,000 and
then soared to over 190 million dollars
at the box office making it one of the
most profitable films of all time
fast-forward a decade and a half and
Jason's production company Blum house
productions holds many of these
staggering box-office records
Academy Awards for whiplash get out and
black clansmen as well as the record for
the biggest wide release box-office flop
from the major studio Jason credits his
success and his ability to take risks
with his business model of low-budget
high concept films generally of the
horror variety he likes to stay relevant
and stay political his latest film the
hunt focuses on a group of wealthy
elites hunting deplorable z' for sport
the original marketing of the film
received a ton of backlash even
garnering flack from President Trump
himself following the awful news of mass
shootings in Ohio and Texas last August
Jason pulled the film from its original
release date but there's been tremendous
buzz about the film ever since now being
marketed is how quote the most talked
about movie of the year is one that no
one's actually seen today in our
conversation we talked all about the
controversy surrounding the release of
the hunt how liberal biases affect
Hollywood and the trial of Jason's
colleague and former boss Harvey
Weinstein
[Music]
hey hey and welcome this is the Ben
Shapiro show Sundays special very
excited to welcome to the show today
Jason Blum just a reminder we'll be
doing some bonus questions at the end
with Jason the only way to get access to
that part of the conversation is to
become a member
head on over to Daley wire.com become a
member and you'll have access to all of
the full conversations with every one of
our awesome guests Jason thanks so much
for joining the show dude thank you for
having me I appreciate it Ravin
coronavirus and everything we're at
Corona Corona Corona Corona and and by
the way like the follow from coronavirus
will probably not be anywhere near as
bad as the fallout from you actually
being here in the first place correct I
think that's absolutely true I'm ready
I'm ready for a wave of hatred I mean
how are you I mean really like I have to
ask you how are you gonna deal with that
because we have had Hollywood figures
have come in here in the past and some
of them like Larry Wilmore was on the
show no problem he was totally fine with
the blow back we've had some Hollywood
figures who have come in here and I've
warned them keep it on the down low and
then they sort of let the cat out of the
bag the world collapses in on them and
they freak out what crazed idea came
into your head that you actually wanted
to come on the show I guess not to turn
it back to the hunt but it will
naturally go back to the hunt the hunt
is about just that the hunt is about
weave the country is so polarized and I
had you know I did a lot of research on
you before I came in here because I was
I was told that and I looked at what
you've said and done and all you've
expressed is a conservative point of
view we I believe a lot of things that
are different than you probably we have
many more things that are that are in
common and share many more beliefs than
our political beliefs and the idea that
we can't talk to each other or I can't
go on your show makes me furious so I
want I've been looking forward to it I'm
ready for the blowback because it
doesn't the the I am on the other side
of the aisle that you are but there are
people who are on my side who were I
think way way too far out there and
people who are on your side or too far
out there and we got to kind of come
together and talk to each other even if
we disagree about things that's that's
my belief that's why I made a hunt
that's why I'm here with you I mean I
really appreciate that because obviously
that is something that I believe too
it's one of the reasons we do the show
and it's one of the things that was so
amazing when you first released the
trailer for the hunt it was perfectly
obvious I mean really just from the
trailer that this was not meant to be
what a lot of pee
on the right including President Trump
immediately took it to me so for those
who don't remember the trailer for the
hunt comes out it is very obvious from
the trailer for the hunt that it is
basically a comedic remake of the most
dangerous game with with folks on the on
the wild Left hunting down rednecks on
the right hunting down the the red state
Trump supporters and is not supposed to
be a wish fulfillment of the left I mean
obvious from the trailer and the right
immediately takes that as no no no this
is just typical Hollywood wish
fulfillment it's a bunch of people
rooting for Hilary Swank playing the
Upper West Side liberal shooting down
these these good noble Americans from
the heartland and it was clear that
wasn't what it was from the first place
were you kind of surprised by the
reaction yeah I was totally surprised I
was totally taken off-guard if I had
anticipated the reaction we would have
had different marketing materials
because because the reaction was so
strong we took it we took the movie off
the schedule because of current events
but could the current events were
magnified by the politics around it and
I didn't we weren't looking for
controversy the purge is a very
controversial subject but people see
that as a movie and it's this crazy
scenario that would never happen and for
some reason the haunt hit a nerve that
we didn't anticipate and yet with the we
got massive blowback from the right and
what I was frustrated about is that no
one had seen the movie people asked
about the president I said I'd love the
president to see the movie and the
second time around the way we introduced
it is we showed it to the media before
we did our marketing so I think people
understood the movie and the movie
really makes fun of both sides movie
does not take sides politically know it
really doesn't want to get into a little
bit more of that in just one second but
first let's talk about the fact that you
have not protected any of your Internet
activity why have you not done this I
know you've been using incognito mode
and because of incognito mode do you
think you are indeed incognito I mean
that's what incognito means but in fact
in incognito mode your online activity
can still be traced even if you clear
your browsing history your ISP can see
every single website you've ever visited
including voxcom
and of course they can sell this
information to tech giant's expressvpn
also encrypt 100% of your data with the
best-in-class
encryption so you know I feel worried
about it anymore your information will
always be protected even when you're
using public Wi-Fi like in a cafe or a
hotel expressvpn will work on everything
phones laptops routers everyone who
shares your Wi-Fi can still be protected
even if they don't themselves have
expressvpn if you have a VPN at this
point I've told you like a thousand
times it's on you bro so protect your
online activity today with the VPN I
trust to secure my privacy visit my
special link and expressive VPN comm
slash Ben you can get an extra three
months for free on a one-year package
that's expr ESS VPN comm slash been
expressed VPN comm slash been to learn
more alrighty so let's talk about the
the hunt itself so again I hadn't seen
the movie was obvious from the trailer
what it was and what it was not but then
I saw the movie and then it was clearly
what the trailer was meaning it makes
fun of both sides the way I've described
it to people is it's basically a Mel
Brooks film with extraordinary levels
that's right and for conservatives who
have been complaining for years about
the standards of political correctness
in Hollywood have been complaining no
one will ever make Blazing Saddles again
nobody will ever be able to make the
producers again this is a movie that
really sort of revels in the stereotypes
on both sides
and is making the argument that those
stereotypes are basically stupid that
there are people who live up to the
stereotypes but that is not the majority
of people and that if you see everybody
as the stereotype then you're missing
the entire point of the American debate
I think that's a fair way of
characterizing the film a hundred
percent that's exactly how I would
characterize it and I would also say
that I one things I agree with the write
about is that I think a lot of Hollywood
including myself I would say is out of
touch with America with the taste of
America and that bothers me too and
that's another reason I love this movie
because it felt like every so often
there's a movie that's like a red state
movie this is not that but but and their
movies like Clint Eastwood for instance
and and there shouldn't be red state
blue state movies there should be good
movies you know and so I don't know that
that spins around on my head and that's
why I wanted to make well I mean that
doesn't just bring me to a question
about how the movie process works in
terms of politics so I wrote an entire
book a while back about bias in
Hollywood particularly in TV industry
there are a lot of folks in Hollywood
some who actually will openly
acknowledge that they won't hire
conservatives they would be just
perfectly open about that and the
complaint from a lot of folks on the
right is that the system in Hollywood is
systemically biased against
conservatives that you can't make
conservative film that if you are openly
conservative in Hollywood there will be
blowback to you what do you make of that
critique of Hollywood in terms of its
political insularity I think that
there's I mean I can't believe that
someone would admit tonight
conservative first of all but also
secondly just not hire a conservative I
mean if you said that about anything
anybody any other kind of group of
people you would be arrested so I think
that's very sad I think there is
somewhat of a biased I think that that's
true and I think that the bias doesn't
take into account the audience and we
try and take that into account well I
mean that is clear from the movie some
of the jokes in the movie are really
over-the-top and they're meant to be
over the top and now that people have
seen the movie what what has been the
reaction I know my reaction was the same
before and after I saw the movie because
it lived up to what I thought it was
gonna be were you surprised by sort of
some of the media reaction to the movie
because on Rotten Tomatoes it's it's
hovering in the sweet spot of where
actual good movies live which is
somewhere between 50 and 70 percents
close if you've got a clone of it fresh
right I'm rotten tomatoes I have a rule
the rule is that with very few
exceptions if it's between 95 and a
hundred percent the movies terrible zero
and forty five percent the movie is also
likely terrible if the movie is between
45 and 60 there's like a 50/50 shot that
it's actually pretty good at 60 and 80
that's the sweet spot of you know it's
gonna be an actual good movie right I
like I like that I like that I like that
III think that's funny we're in the
earth those two your sweet spot yeah
we're about 55 actually I thought the
money would be better reviewed I really
did I thought we'd get better reviews
you were too fair I mean I'll be honest
with you I know why why really the
answer is because you gave the you made
jokes about people who don't like having
jokes made about them right your the
movie actually is making fun of the
critics I mean a lot a lot of the
critics have viewpoints about red state
America that are actually the the parody
of what exactly what your parroting so a
lot of people see that and they go into
that high dudgeon that's not funny kind
of stuff but of course it is funny like
all this stuff that the right finds
funny it's a movie that is geared to
please no one and piss off everyone in
in a certain way and which I think it's
the point of film yeah and that if you
can get past that and just enjoy it then
we'll be a better country for and I
totally agree with that like if you can
laugh at yourself and laugh at the other
guy you're gonna be better off than then
otherwise and you'll listen to each
other more I think we've stopped
listening to each other both sides no
one listens everyone talks at each other
and no one listens and I think one of
the ways to get people to listen and
we're not going to accomplish big things
unless we're working together and one of
the ways to get people to
is to make jokes and if you can make
jokes and laugh at yourself and laughing
the site just like you said you start to
listen and maybe find a way some kind of
compromise to work forward on different
things I mean frankly one of the reasons
I was impressed with the film is because
so the so it's written by Damon Lindelof
who obviously is of the political left
and then I don't know Nick uses politics
is he he's Carlton's son correct he's a
Republican okay so right so I've met
Carlton before I actually interviewed
him briefly and so the crossed the aisle
writing of it that's evidence like I was
gonna say bad Democrat I would been out
been shocked yeah
totally by that but it is it is clear
like who wrote what part of right right
and it really it does hit on a lot of
those themes and so I wanted to
congratulate you on that because it's so
easy to fall into the trap of only
making jokes about one song this is
really really well done on that so yeah
oh good yeah and we weren't interested
in doing that we weren't interested in
lacerating one side we were interested
in last writing both so I want to talk
about sort of the movies that you
produce more broadly sure also so you
have a unique film production strategies
which is you don't make these huge 50 to
100 million dollar blockbuster movies
your strategy is to pick good scripts
that don't cost a fortune then just make
a fortune off of them so how exactly did
you hit on the Strand because you have
the money obviously the cash flow how
did you hit on the strategy of making
movies that are in this sort of low
budget to mid budget sweet spot as
opposed to the big movies the big
tentpole flicks yes so I was working in
the movie business for about 15 years
from 20 to 35 and I kind of had one foot
in independent film and one foot in
studio film and really what you're
talking about is the difference between
independent and studio movies in terms
of budgets average independent movies
four or five million dollars average to
do movies 75 million dollars and I never
was comfortable in either space and I
and I was really frustrated by the way
studio films are produced but I love the
way studio films were distributed I made
a crazy I'm not crazy I made an unusual
movie for me called the tooth fairy
starring the rock right that's the only
studio film I ever made and I had this
very frustrating experience making the
movie but I saw how a studio distributed
a movie but that was amazing because my
only experience and distribution had
been independent distribution
independent distribution is broken it's
one person kind of drawing a DVD box and
making the poster and making guys just
so it's so hard to compete with the
studios
and at that time when I was 35 - movies
that I worked on very different movies
paranormal activity and the Tooth Fairy
came out at the same time and the rate
and lucky thing that I had to happen to
me during my career was that paranormal
activity happened to me after I'd been
at it for 15 years and after I had that
hit movie Hollywood says cuz Hollywood
is addicted to money
Hollywood says if you have a hit make
them more expensive movie that's what
every agent tells their director you
directed of 20 million dollar movie now
you're ready for an 80 million dollar
movie it and I think that's garbage
I think the the larger the budget of a
movie like I said I didn't like doing
bigger but the more every creative
decision is by committee the way you
choose movies when there are a hundred
million dollars plus is they have to be
like other movies that were successful
and they have to feel like those movies
three successful movies have to feel
like that in the last five years when
you make a low-budget movies it's the
opposite you could totally take risks
you can hire directors who aren't hot
you can hire actors who aren't famous
you can tell stories where the lead
character gets shot in 30 30 minutes
into the movie you know you can take
creative risks so to your point I could
actually I obviously I could make
expensive movies now but I don't have
any interest in making expensive movies
I like working with low budgets and
doing subversive crazy things and
sometimes they're like the hunt or get
out or split and they really hit and
sometimes they don't but when they don't
we don't have to close our company we
just keep going we release the movie
straight to streaming and we keep moving
on and I love that I mean this seems so
obvious why hasn't the rest of Hollywood
caught on to any of this why are they
banking on these 200 million-dollar
movies of the dr. Dolittle's of the
holes when they can lose their
shirts on well I think it's it's a
complicated we're a little more
complicated than this but a big part of
it is ego and this idea of success means
expensive like if you're a big hotshot
producer you should be producing 150
million dollar movies and as silly as
that sounds that's a big part of it now
obviously 10 pull movies are a big part
of the movie business and Marvel movies
and and and Pixar movies and Lucas Lucas
for you know if Disney Auld is that
those it's a big important part of the
business but it gets too much attention
I think because Hollywood thinks bigger
better how do you make choices about
which sort of movies you want to do so
one of the big critiques of especially a
lot of tentpole films now is that there
almost seems to be a quota as far as we
need this many women in the movie or I
mean there's many minorities in in the
movies
the that we need to make movies with
this particular level of messaging in
order to please the critics and and so
you end up with this sort of these
movies that are politically designed to
please everyone and end up actually
pissing off everybody right yeah it's in
the Marvel movies where they'll sort of
say okay well we don't have enough gay
character so we need a gay character so
we'll throw in this little hint of a gay
character right here just enough so that
GLAAD won't be on our ass and then not
enough that it actually pisses off the
13 year olds who are coming to the movie
or the parents more important right so
how do you decide how to make because
you're making controversial films I mean
films that have something to say about
our politics the I would say the hunt is
pleasing to people on the right but
obviously the politics of get out I mean
I did a review of get out on my show I
sent this a beautifully made film I mean
the politics enraged me I thought of
course get out I was like I don't
understand what like what I had serious
problems obviously what the politics of
get out I mean I thought that the racial
themes of it or deeply off-putting to me
sure but yeah but you're taking those
kinds of risks so how do you decide how
which scripts you're interested in doing
well I think it to your point when
you're making a movie that when you're
making movies that are that big they
have to appeal to four quadrants you
know so very specifically we have a
meeting on Monday morning we look at a
script we all come in we talk about it
on Monday morning someone has to love it
I have to love it or some other thing
about yes to love it we have to think
it's scary or unnerving in some way
because that's kind of what blum house
means to us or to me but then the fourth
thing is which is what I was talking
about before which is very different
from how a studio green lights a movie
is it has to feel new and different and
if a studio has a movie for a hunt if I
was running a studio and there was a
hundred million dollar movie and my
executive had a production set this
feels great it's new and different I'd
say for a hundred million dollars over
my dead body
right so I'm not it's the only way it's
not the studio system it's just if
budgets are that big it's you're
responsible to take risks creatively big
swings creatively but you can take them
on my bunch of movies so right now
obviously we're watching as Kron
virus unfolds theaters in China are
largely shut down that obviously
provides an enormous amount of money to
Hollywood
you have theaters in the United States
likely are going to shut down if not
unmasked then people are just not going
because big crowds are bad right now so
how does this change the model of
Hollywood Howard was already suffering
with the movement from theater
screenings to to streaming streaming is
under absolute threat to theaters
obviously the revenue is moving in that
direction it's unclear whether that's
even sustainable because Netflix is
shelling out billions of dollars in
making basically she's throwing anything
at the wall that they hope can stick
where do you see the future of Hollywood
going you see fragmenting into a bunch
of streaming services do you think that
theatrical film is basically going to
die where do you see all this is going I
think it's not realistic to think all
the studios are gonna wave for months
before they put a movie at home they
just can't compete with they're gonna
have to compete with Amazon and Netflix
and Apple in a different way so I think
that's changing I think in the beginning
of your question question I think I
don't know what's gonna happen but
definitely you know one of the funny
Coronas gonna have much bigger effects
on a lot of other things but in terms of
to answer your question it's going to
fundamentally I think affect the movie
business because of not just while it
happens but when we're through it which
hopefully will be sooner rather than
later there's they're going to be shifts
they're going to be shifts the consumer
is going to be more used to staying at
home something is gonna give there has
to be something that's gonna happen post
Corona I don't know what it is we're one
one day of two days into it but but I
definitely agree with you that the movie
business will look different after the
coronavirus all that said how does that
impact genres like horror so horizontal
that almost demands to be seen with
other people because the feeling of
dread that exists when you watch a movie
on your own like if you're streaming a
movie and you can just pause it at the
scary part and go to the bathroom that
obviously radically changes how you film
how you see any of these films the
horror movie experience does require
somebody in the back of the theater
shouting don't go into that don't go oh
don't open that door alright so how does
that change the movie making from from
your perspective well I don't think
theaters are ever gonna go away I think
people are gonna go to movie theaters to
see movies just like people go pay $300
to see live theater when they could go
to a movie or people still go to the
movies when
TV was invented I think the collective
experience of going to a theater and
taking in a movie I think that's gonna
be around for a long time I think
there'll be less movies in theaters
there'll be a less maybe a less of a
selection or I should say they'll be
there'll be many many fewer movies in
theaters with a window and I think there
may be many more movies in theaters but
they only last for a week or two and I
think horror it was gonna continue to
work I think kids are oh I think we're I
think I'm safe anyway for better for
worse kids are gonna want to go
collectively to a movie theater to be
scared at a horror movie and to your
point horror specifically is people
watch it on streaming but it is almost
impossible to be scared watching a
horror movie on streaming less for the
break but more because almost any other
genre other filmmakers will be very mad
if I said this but almost any other
genre you can look down and look at an
email and look up you're not gonna miss
too much but the way s you might maybe
maybe on comedy with a joke but maybe I
think even horror is more the way to
scare a good scare the way James Wan or
Leigh Whannell does a scare it's super
choreographed you have to be paying
attention all the way up to the scare
for the scare to work and if you look
away for 10 seconds a minute before that
scare happens the scare won't be scary
so in that way you know you're really
right like watching a scary movie at
home it's never gonna be scary or never
gonna be nearly as scary as it is the
movie theater because people don't lose
their focus when they're in the theater
I mean horror is immersive in a way that
other genres just don't have to be
because as you say like you could look
away from the screen on any of these
other movies you do that like right
before the jump scare and you miss being
scared yeah exactly or even if you look
that the the it's the build-up to the
jump sure that makes the jump scare
scary so if you look away five minutes
before the jump scare then you see the
jump scare you're not gonna think it's
scary so looking forward to sort of what
the streaming services are experiencing
so if there's a lot of folks right now
who are saying you know now's a great
time to buy stock in the stream yeah
yeah because everybody's not spending
tons of time at home and and they're
gonna be streaming everything but at the
same time right I mean just before this
coronavirus panic happened there was a
lot of talk about whether Netflix was
even going to be viable into the into
the mid term just because how are they
even making their revenue like they're
only a certain number of people on
planet earth we're going to be paying
into that into that service
they are expending such enormous amounts
of money to bring new contents all the
time and also because of the binging
effect you have to generate so much
content right because everything is now
generated in ten hour blocks as opposed
to two hour blocks how can you continue
to pay people this much money in terms
of production fee and then continue to
maintain a studio what something has to
give here I don't know on Netflix I mean
they had their first mover advantage
they're gonna have there's a lot more
people left they have gonna have 200
million subscribers it's a lot of
revenue I mean I think they had such a
they were smarter than everybody else
for so long no one took them seriously
they ate everyone else's lunch I think
it's gonna be I think it's gonna take
and in a recession I don't think you're
cancelling your $12 you're not gonna go
to the theater but you're definitely not
cancelling your $12 subscription to
Netflix so I don't know I think they're
here for the long run they hasn't been
profitable yet though and that'll be
interesting to when that and when that
has to happen it'll be interesting to
see how it changes and I do wonder if
you know they because of the first mover
advantage they did have that significant
advantage but now you see other services
I mean you've got Hulu out there which
is now partnering with Disney Plus and
you got you got qui be I mean like
literally a thousand different versions
of streaming and and so you're basically
gonna be duplicating your cable package
to exactly five dollars ago okay exactly
so that is sort of the worry for Netflix
is it I suppose that could generate a
lot of competition for some of the
movies that you're making from yeah
services I think there were four Netflix
to is as as you have so much choice in
streaming why are you not gonna
subscribe to Netflix for months watch
what you need to watch cancel I've
literally apple eyes yeah there you go
so I think I think that I think they're
gonna start seeing that too and we don't
know how that data is reported when they
say X amount of subscribers does that
mean they're subscribing all the time or
part of the time maybe that's public I
don't know so you obviously like doing
films with a political orientation what
drives you towards sort of the
controversial and and the political as
opposed to just the the art because
you've made stuff that it really is not
political sure and in his wonderful I
mean I've been a huge fan of the film
whiplash since it first came out I
bought it on DVD I then bought it on
streaming I mean it really I've
recommended it to everybody I put it in
my top ten list of the last ten years
Wow it's it's fantastic so well what
makes you want to do political film into
the hornet's nest I don't want to do
good scary entertaining visceral fun
movies that
first and foremost if there happens to
be kind of a political political person
if there happens to be a political bent
to it I'm attracted to that but it's not
a it's not a priority it's not a mandate
for the company my executives aren't
sitting with filmmakers saying like what
issue do you want issue-oriented movie
do you want to do there are companies
that do that we do not I would even go
so far to say if I'm sitting with a
director and they say like you know you
may get out you made the purge you made
the hunt like I want to do a political
movie I want to do it about X topic I
want to do about global warming I I say
we're in trouble
because you can't I think it's virtually
impossible to make a fun entertaining
movie and think of the topic first I
think you have to think about what
what's in your heart that's like super
scary and whatever and if you can fold
politics into that Jordan thinks about
race all the time clearly he was he was
brought up by mixed race parents and so
he thinks about it's something that it's
on his mind all the time so get out came
out of his head
but Reagan peels sketches obvious yeah
clearly obviously obviously but I don't
think it has to be organic to the artist
it can't be like just like I said like
you can't like I want to say mega story
about global warming I'm gonna make a
make a scary story about it we I'll tell
you a funny funny story we did it where
that where we did exactly that is Barry
Levinson lives on a the Chesapeake Bay
which was very polluted and he wanted to
make a documentary about the Chesapeake
Bay and as agent said you know you
should make a documentary you should
make a horror movie about the Chesapeake
Bay and many more people will see it we
made it it's called the bay nobody saw
[Laughter]
any should say this because this has
been my lead advice to to conservatives
who say they want to get into film so
one of the great one of the great
complaints of conservatives about the
Hollywood again is not only that it's
politically biased but why aren't there
more conservative films made and what I
always say to them is because
conservatives have kind of a dolphin
brain when it comes to entertainment
which is they say that they are
interested in conservative entertainment
but then when it comes time to fund it
they're like well I'd actually rather
invest in fracking and then when it
comes to what they want to watch what
they actually want to watch is the same
stuff that everybody else wants to watch
and so the only kind of films that you
can get conservatives to pledge to see
are either openly religious films so
it's basically an all right call
or politically overt films where again
is sort of adopted like you'll do better
off a documentary there's openly about
about anything that's because there are
there are films that have fairly
conservative themes I mean one of my
colleagues here Andrew Clavin famously
suggested that the Dark Knight had some
pretty conservative themes about
government surveillance in the role of
government surveillance in American
society and all of us and but but
conservatives who are interested in film
tend to think of the thematic first
because they're thinking through that
prism they think of their childhood
first or their you know what there's
some intimate story or some story that
they've that they're attached to and
then if they're interested in getting
conservative values out there and
entertainment that will bleed through
but they have to think of the story
first so how did you get into this
industry in the first place
I graduated college in 1991 and I my
roommate was Noah Baumbach who's a
writer director he and I were roommates
at college and he we were roommates at
Chicago we were we lived in Chicago I
sold cable TV door-to-door to support
myself which was amazing Commission only
I would say I learned more about
producing for doing that than anything
else and and Noah wrote this script
which was initially called fifth-year
which is about four guys who love
college so much they made up excuses to
say they're an extra year it was clearly
about all of us and and I got that movie
made through the you know various
hustling I got the movie made and that
kind of started it came out it was
called kicking and screaming we changed
the title so was that was the and I'm an
associate producer and it got me a job
at a little company called arrow and
that's how my career started how did
that progress into what you do now I
mean you're the head of one of the
biggest studios in the it progressed
let's see I so I worked at arrow
I graduated from cable television to
real estate I got my real estate license
in New York I was a real rented
apartments in New York which I also
loved which was also great training to
be a producer some producers really a
seller I after I left arrow I went to
work for Miramax I work for Miramax to
95 to 2000 I always wanted my own
company and I moved to LA in 2000 I
produced a bunch of independent movies
most of which were really really not
good
and and then this connects to where we
started which is I got to being 35 I got
lucky enough to get involved with
paranormal activity and kind of forced
the Tooth Fairy to happen and
that was the genesis of Blum house when
those two movies came out I step back I
said hey I think that what I want to do
is make low-budget scary movies because
you can get a studio to release them but
make them weird and different and
subversive and and I always say that we
kind of sneak these Sundance dramas
almost into the skin of a genre movie to
get him distributed and that's that's
what we did we do 50% of our business
has movies and 50% is television but our
television company really only started
about three or four years ago so that's
relatively new but now I spend about
half and TV in half in movies well you
always a horror guy I mean in terms of
now he's like no I wasn't I was always a
funny thing as I was always a horror guy
in my heart in other words I have a lot
in common with people in the
storytelling horror world with our
directors I'm weird I'm here on your
show I do things against the grain I was
kind of I was not kind of I was
definitely a loser in high school and
you know I did weird collected my
fingernails when I was a kid like I was
a weird okay and horror people in horror
are odd so in that way I was always a
a person but I did not grow up
loving horror movies I love movies I
loved as Friday the 13th scared me to
death
you know but I found it was funny when I
did proud of like today I was like oh
gosh and this is what I should be doing
this is where I belong and you know when
I have the opportunity now to do movies
that sway away from it I have
occasionally I always think they're
little connected even black Klansmen you
know they're about dark subjects they're
about scary things Roger Ailes to me
scary maybe less scary to you and Roger
Ailes we're talking about fair enough
fair enough I just found my home with
with with scary stuff so who are your
own creative influences like what were
the movies the Hitchcock is the is the
that he's our great you know when I
think of our a model movie and the
movies that we're trying to I don't want
to say I guess tip our hat to it so it's
Hitchcock movies regardless of your
feelings about get out I feel like get
out was a fairy
oh no it's beautifully made beautifully
made great they're they're shots that
are obviously I mean vertigo that the
famous shot of him
not as obvious right with a vertigo yeah
so it's a very Hitchcockian feeling so
we have to talk about your politics
since obviously we're talking about the
politics of the hunt so you look at the
state of politics in America right now
and you'd said earlier that you think
that there's more that brings us
together than sort of divides us
it's a contention that I think is
largely try used to place a lot of my
faith in people who are politically
oriented for the future of the country
and now I think that all the people who
pay no attention to politics are
basically that that's our there I agree
or informed you are the more you hate
the people on the other yes I think so
too
I agree I completely agree with that so
where would you characterize your own
politics me I'm definitely I'm a
Democrat for sure those are those that's
what I believe in and is that based on
sort of the the government expenditure
side or more on the social policy side
or I believe I should pay higher taxes I
think rich people should pay more taxes
I'm rich I think I should pay more taxes
I think the government should provide a
safety net which I know is different
than you know what what what what
Republicans think for people who care I
think if people can't manage in society
for whatever reason they're lazy or any
other reason that that you could come up
with if they're on the street we should
take care of them in a very in the most
basic way but everyone in this super
rich country should at least have a room
to live in and a hot meal or whatever so
I and I would be more than happy if all
my me and all my rich friends paid more
taxes to help that California is the
perfect state for you so how's it going
out here not going very well I was happy
to live here until I got hit with that
13.3% top tax rate right and I looked
around at the fact that the government
services that I've supposedly am paying
for have not materialized in any actual
is only better than it was going better
a couple of years ago doing very well
it's like it's very frustrating
California is extremely frustrating they
have the biggest tax base they have more
money than everybody else and we have
terrible social problem and it is it is
pretty horrendous and and I mean again I
think on principle very few people
disagree with the idea that we need to
take care of people who literally can't
take care of themselves and so there's
the difference
I think if you're lazy you don't want to
work if you're lazy and you want and you
want to live on $20,000 a year I think
you should be entitled to live on 20,000
I think if you're lazy then you should
get off your ass but say yeah and
rehanging you'll get along anyway at
Andrew I love Andrew and I love it the
only charming person left in American
politics I agree I loved a lot of his
idea I love a lot of his ideas and
actually like a real person like we
asked every single Democratic contender
to come on the show not single one what
except for Andrew and aim for him and he
was great he was great I think he's a
lot of fun I loved him I have big hopes
for him in the future yeah and I hope
that he runs from arrant it would be I
think I don't want to be better than the
de Blasio I mean I do I do not like the
mayor of me once I'm this late for
glumly house you have a bunch of movies
that are coming on the slate is so we
have the purge later this summer
I hope subject to Corona then we have a
next Halloween movie we did we're gonna
do three Halloween movies so the middle
one is is in October and then we have
one more next year which I'm which is
I'm super excited about on the TV side
we have this this show about John Brown
called good Lord bird super pumped about
I told you before the show I wrote the
script on John Brown I didn't sue paren
to the John Brown story so you showed me
a limit at the preview it looks
unbelievable secret shown of the trailer
Ethan Hawke plays John Brown and I think
I'm really excited about I think it's
gonna be really cool well Ethan Hawke is
John Brown is just fantastic casting cuz
he is slightly off and you're very proud
of what you showed me in the previews
just amazing oh good I can be crazy I
cannot wait for it you get a lot of a
list actors to join up on these little
budget films how does that even work
well now it's very easy because we've
paid we when we when we do Polly wood is
famous for net this is actually kind of
probably meant might be interesting for
your audience
Holly Hollywood is famous for pretending
to share our not sharing um we'd to give
net profits and you never get pay I was
on the receiving end of that I have net
profits of 10 movies I've never gotten a
single penny so I always said if I have
my own company I'm never gonna do net
profits I'm gonna say in variety used to
open it but you now you get them on your
phone when you're looking at variety and
the movies done 30 million dollars I'm
gonna give you $100,000 it's done 40 I'm
gonna give you another hundred
so I actually deliver the checks myself
to FedEx I've done it for years so when
our movies hit certain
we pay immediately and I film it and I
send it to the recipient of the cheque
we've done that for a long long time and
over the years I've paid out an enormous
amount of money in profits to
third-party participants to actors and
directors have worked on our movies so
now we have it's very easy to get famous
people to work for nothing upfront
because we've paid we have a great track
record of paying maybe the only the only
honest person in Hollywood I mean I have
heard of everyone's heard of Hollywood
accounting and double bookkeeping
happening here so were you the only
person who just decided to not cheat
people no no no definitely not but i but
i but I'm only I'm the one of the only
people who insisted on keeping it super
super transparent and that's what we do
and that's what we still do okay so I
promised that I would get back to
President Trump and I didn't I didn't
any delay it long enough for the
suspense to be right I really I tossed
the time you night just like I showed
all my cards when I said it was so
relieved I know and then is you
basically obligated I do ask you more
questions and I'm a so-so
President Trump there few Hollywood
obviously despises President Trump one
of the things that is that is very weird
about that is just that Trump is a
Hollywood creation in the first place
like the fact is room that Trump is a
person who was not wildly successful at
business Hollywood decided to portray
him as wildly successful at business and
excellent at firing people it turns out
that he actually it's actually one of
the things he's worst at as president
earlier like he'll wait he'll find ten
different ways together to try and fire
themselves will fire people while
they're on the toilet he'll fire people
in ways that put him in teachable
territory like yeah Hollywood created
President Trump in a lot of ways and
then became very very sad that they had
created President Trump and
Frankenstein's monster came back to the
castle so what what words do you have
for Hollywood for having brought and
president Trump to the world start with
that now that's too far-fetched you
cannot blame Hollywood for President
Trump you really kid you can and I and
blame but you cannot blame Hollywood you
could maybe you know you can't even
blame New York City of a president Trump
I can't accept that
I can't accept the premise of the
question I will not I will not refuse to
my question because I don't accept the
premise of the question but I'm going to
force you to accept the premise of the
question so here's the reason the reason
being that Hollywood one of the things
that's fascinating about President
Hollywood created
certain way information is consumed and
I think I think Trump one of the reasons
Trump a president Trump was elected was
because the way that we consume
information has been changed by the
media industry across Hollywood and New
York I think that that part is the
building of this image I mean he was on
the what the Emmy Awards or the it was
the Tony's rather singing Green Acres
ten years ago no one was building up his
image with the plan of making him
president well right but actually this
gets just sort of a deeper point which
is one of the things that's fascinating
about the interaction between Hollywood
and DC is is that in DC people from
Hollywood are the celebrities and
Hollywood people from DC are the
celebrities and there is this there is
this feeling in Hollywood again I've
grown up here my entire life that the
people that Hollywood people want to
meet are not really other Hollywood
people they're people the politician so
President Obama was actually more of a
Hollywood star to Hollywood than he was
even just you know a statesman or a
politician or anything he was the in a
certain way Trump's entertainment
persona is almost like a bizarro
Superman version of Barack Obama I mean
President Obama was very media savvy
President Obama was very heavily
involved with Hollywood President Obama
campaign with movie stars he brought
movie stars to the White House she was
very camera friendly and all of which
was true and now he's a producer right
and now he's a producer so what do you
make of sort of the merger between
entertainment and politics that really
does precede Trump I mean people now
sort of pretend that certainly was the
font of this but he clearly was not no
no Fox News was the beginning of it I
mean Fox News really started to blur the
line between information and news and
entertainment now it's a crow now CNBC
now they all do it by the way I'm not
suggesting that Fox News is the only
company that does it now now it's across
all platforms but I think when you I
think I mean I'm talking slightly
different than what you're saying but I
think one of the things Hollywood is
very guilty of is blurring the lines
between news and entertainment our truth
and fiction and that for sure is
something that Hollywood did what do you
think Hollywood's attitudes toward Indre
intervention in politics should be so
we've seen this kind of break out in the
open with for example Ricky Gervais dust
hammering people at the awards shows
saying listen you're a bunch of
Hollywood Knights you know you're going
and doing business with China Tim Cook
from Apple while you're sitting here
bitching about president Trump and his
and his policies toward China everybody
in this audience is very rich and has
spent five minutes reading a book and
now they're talking pausing what what do
you think there's a lot of Americans who
watched that and agreed with Ricky
Gervais what do you think that
hollywood's attitude should be toward
political involvement and and not even
just being involved politically on a
personal level but in terms of sort of
promulgating political messages more
broadly we asked a lot of questions
there yeah I think I think Ricky Gervais
is I think if you're a saying do I think
Hollywood is hypocritical
I think wildly wildly wildly do I think
Hollywood is that a touch yes
do I think Hollywood should probably dip
its toe less into politics and more into
keeping its eye on the prize which is
entertaining people absolutely that's
the first thing that you asked what was
the second thing you asked I mean that
really was sort of the quad I was a yeah
I mean because I think it's I think I
think I think Hollywood would do you
know fine with getting into politics
less than they do I guess you know what
I just I want to refrain that I think
Hollywood I think Hollywood is entitled
to be political what I what I don't like
is when Hollywood gets preachy right and
that bothers me I try not to do that and
that bothers me I think when Hollywood
gets preached here or when Hollywood
says we're right and you're wrong that
works me so in a second I want to ask
you about an area where Hollywood
finally did get it right but originally
got it wrong namely the me to movement
because you've come up as somebody who
Harvey Weinstein was afraid of something
you should be inordinately proud of I
mean if I were you I'd be more proud of
this than any movie I'd produce now in
my agency spoilers say now here's where
people don't read the facts I'm worried
you saying that I should be proud of it
some people some people are not going to
hurt them right so let's just make it
very clear yeah Hollywood had a red flag
list for people he was worried about who
were talking badly about him and I was
on the list and I I'm happy that I mean
ordinarily proud of that obviously like
I everybody you know should have been
calling out Harvey Weinstein for what he
was three years why do you think it was
that he wasn't called out four years I
mean the fact is the casting couch
unfortunately was a way of life in
Hollywood for a hundred years but why do
you think that why yeah well III was I
was gonna the second part I was gonna
say is you know
I wish that it was true but what he said
about me you know I wasn't doing that it
because I didn't know and I think a huge
majority of the people around him didn't
know it I mean I was relatively close to
him and I remember even a couple of
lawsuits being settled and I remember
being very clearly told you know I mean
I was young I was 28 years old so I
guess I was impressionable but I
remember being told I can look Harvey's
a very big person big famous person and
big famous people are often taken
advantage of and a couple of assistants
took advantage of him and he paid them
off it never occurred I said make that
make sense
I bought that totally so I I don't think
there was this big conspiracy protecting
Harvey I just I just can't believe that
that's true um do you think that
Hollywood at least parts of Hollywood
turned a blind eye I do what I mean
people were making open jokes about
those rights like Seth MacFarlane made a
joke about it at the Oscars his
reputation with regard to women he had a
terrible reputation as regard to it but
that's very different than being a
rapist or someone who's does sexual
assault definitely I mean I think you
know he was a brute tough guy but I
don't think Seth implied he was breaking
the law I think it's I think that's a
there's a big difference between those
things so I want to ask you sort of what
you think are the misperceptions that
that conservatives have about Hollywood
generally so it you know I've brought a
lot of sort of the conservative
critiques of Hollywood to you and voted
them in your feet and said answer these
but what are the things that that you
wish that people in the middle of the
country they wish that conservatives who
may be anti Hollywood almost in
knee-jerk fashion knew about the
Hollywood industry in the way that it
works in the people who staff it well I
like the biggest thing I think and then
the most important thing and the reason
that I'm doing your show is that all of
Hollywood is not the same you know we're
different I can I can be a liberal but
talk to you and be on your show and make
a movie called the hunt and make a movie
for I even I make even a movie with if
there was a amazing horror movie that
came to me and it pushed a conservative
value I would make it so I think that
that's I think that's probably the most
important thing one of the things that
I've often said to conservatives because
I grew up in this area and I know a lot
of people who are in Hollywood is that
you would be surprised the number of
people who either are conservative in
Hollywood or who at least live normal
conservative
lifestyles even if they politically
disagree with you right having that I
guess that's the other misconception is
this idea of like Hollywood is like you
know snortin collage and stuff like that
I have the most I have two little kids I
have the most I have literally I live
talk to anyone who works me I lived the
most conservative lifestyle a bed at ten
o'clock every night I take my kid to
school I put my kids to bed every night
like I lived what is the archetype of a
conservative although I'm not a
conservative so do you have hopes that
with movies like the hunt that people
will actually learn to laugh again
because it seems like the biggest
problem here and this was true in the
original reaction then it seems true
from a lot of the critics now is that
people just don't want to laugh at this
stuff because they're almost happy with
a world in which you can't make a movie
like this there's a whole group of
people who seem happier not being able
to tell jokes to each other and instead
snipe at each other on Twitter which is
just a garbage fire of dunking and being
dunked upon do you think that there is
going to be a reawakening of that there
has been there has to be a rear it's too
stifling there has to be a reawakening
and you see it in the art that's being
created people are so afraid of being
taken down by the right or being taken
down by the left and both sides are
equally vicious that they're curbing
what they do where and I would say we
you know and III really push hard not to
do that as you know if you do this this
is gonna happen I say if I go to your
show XY is he's gonna happen I say screw
it I'm gonna do the show same thing if
you make this movie if you make this a
if you do this do you really want to
deal with the controversy I 99 times out
of 100 not every time but almost every
time I say yes because I think you have
to keep doing things and and get the
controversy until they realize that the
controversy is not helpful it's not
productive it's it's it's making people
afraid to speak and I think that's
terrible you know I think people make
mistakes I think people say things they
don't mean like that should we're all
human and the idea that you can no you
can't you have to everything has to be
sobre hearse and you can't say anything
without being attacked if it's somewhat
offends some group of people I don't
know I just I can't stand that and I'm
it's gonna definitely change I hope it
changes sooner rather than later
it means the pendulum is gonna swing
back in the positive side of it
the pendulum there's an argument to be
made the pendulum had to get all the way
out here and I would even say this about
the president which is in my view we had
to have someone for a Democrat we had to
have someone like him or not as extreme
you could definitely agree he's extreme
unusual there's never been a president
like the current president never an
arguable and we needed even that the
Democrats needed that to be shaken up to
say hey listen you know it's it's super
important to me like hey listen you're
so foolish you care which you're helping
poor people Bush you're not you're
helping yourself you're helping New York
and LA you're not listening to what
people in the country need and guess
what we're trying someone else and I
think we needed that to be shaken up
eventually eventually now it's gonna be
like we're quoted as we needed president
Jason's but I was relating that to you
know there's part of the noise that's
good you know it's good you can't you
know women or live in a much safer
America today than they did two years
ago that's good getting there was sloppy
and messy and not fun yeah no I mean I
totally agree with this and I think that
that is the fine line is between
obviously there are some people I've
been hit on the on the right for saying
that there are some people who I think
are indeed outside the Overton Window I
don't think that means that they should
be D platformed or that they shouldn't
be able to say what they want to say
they should be able to and then we
should be able to talk about how them
they are but there are people who are
clearly not within sort of the
mainstream of public rhetoric the
problem is that we are shrinking that
mainstream so small that if you don't
fit inside this very tiny box then who
exactly does I mean and that's that's
been one of the problems for the right I
think that it'll it miss test in
Hollywood it's a problem for the left -
yeah well it's certainly a problem
for for the left in terms of the right I
think I mean it seems like there's still
some pretty significant litmus test in
Hollywood politically less so I think on
sort of the pro-life pro-choice stuff I
think I know some pro lifers who are
working in Hollywood I think that do you
think Trump is a litmus test like how
many people do you know in Hollywood who
have actually who are working who will
admit to openly have voting have voted
for president
like I think that that is still reading
this testing in Hollywood 3 I mean I'm
gonna be them probably a very very few
yeah I mean what's your point my point
my point in saying that is that the
Overton Window in Hollywood is obviously
still incredibly operational but that if
you weren't as lead I get a lot of
questions from people in my audience you
say I really want to work in Hollywood I
love storytelling
I'm afraid that because I was a member
of students for Trump that now I'm gonna
go to Hollywood and that's on my
Facebook page and I'm not going to get a
job because you have to come to our
office we'll give you a job in a second
um I don't know
I mean maybe you know I don't know I
think that that's that's a problem but I
think that that's gonna change but I
think that you're right I think I can't
tell you that that's not true so in a
second I want to ask you a final
question I don't ask you what of all the
movies that you've made what is your
favorite if you had to pick one one of
your babies but if you actually want to
hear the final answer from Jason Blum
then you're going to have to go over to
Daily wire calm and subscribe you can
hear the rest of our conversation there
be sure to check out Jason's new film
the hunt Jason thank you so much for
stopping by and get ready for the deluge
my friend I'm ready
alrighty thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
avenge Shakira shows Sunday special is
directed by Mike Joyner and produced by
Mathis clobbers executive producer
Jeremy boring associate producer case
Winterton our guests are booked by
Caitlyn Manor post-production is
supervised by Alex's Singaram editing is
by Jim Nichol audio is mixed by Mike
Carmina hair and makeup is by Anika
Geneva cradle graphics are by Cynthia
and gula the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday
special is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
[Music]